hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the columnist for the i ian dunt and the
broadcaster and former government
minister anna subre uh they'll be with
us now uh until just before midnight
thank you both very much for joining us
today welcome to you both
now let's see what is on the front of
some of those pages the guardian leads
with concerns that are packed over
nuclear submarines between the uk the us
and australia could inflame tensions
with china
the times reports on theresa may's
question to the prime minister asking
whether the new alliance could drag the
uk into a war with china over taiwan
the mail leads on news that travel
testing rules are going to be eased for
people who are fully vaccinated
according to the telegraph the home
secretary priti patel has urged decisive
action against climate protesters who
have twice blocked the m25 this week
the financial times understands the
chancellor rishi sunak will use his
budget speech next month to announce a
series of measures designed to curve
government borrowing
and the metro hears from the sports
presenter gavin ramjun who expresses his
disgust the tweets sent to him
containing anti-asian racial slurs were
deemed not to have violated twitter's
policies on hate speech
well as i said we are joined tonight by
ian dunt and anna subray uh welcome to
you both lots of uh interesting front
pages to look at this evening uh and
you've chosen to kick off ian we'll
start with you uh with the guardian page
one uh and this is about this uh trade
deal orcas uh and and the fact that
possibly it could provoke china uh
according to the guardian
well i think the chinese are you know
able to read between the lines you
didn't have to be sort of an
investigative journalist to try and work
out where it was um the us and britain
and australia were coming from this is
clearly a policy
to control any kind of expansion from
china and trying to put them slightly
more in their place we've had a long
long period of essentially trying to be
friends with the chinese of essentially
allowing chinese to continue
as they were
now i think probably partly as a sort of
overreaction to some of the humiliation
that we saw of the west over afghanistan
we've seen the us the uk and australia
line up very very strongly indeed and
it's provoked exactly the kind of
reaction you would expect from china the
kind of reaction you would expect from
france on the basis of you know france
lost out on some submarine contracts
that it had already deposited a lot of
money in but nevertheless i mean i can't
imagine that anyone was surprised by the
sort of response we see from china or
anyone will be particularly put off by
it anna do you think this is a good deal
for the uk
we've got to see haven't we i mean i
think one of the things i find peculiar
is there's no mention in any of this
about the impact on nato it seems that
sort of nato's increasingly being
sidelined and everything and as i agree
absolutely with what ian says in his
analysis uh and understandably the
french achieved i think the thing that
really struck me though was that theresa
may increasingly is playing the role of
the leader of the unofficial opposition
if not the actual opposition um and
because it was her question that yeah
and it was a good question from her
where she specifically asked about
taiwan and she says and it's uh it's
reported um in both the guardian and and
in the times that
she asks the question to johnson in the
house of commons today she said you know
what happens if china goes and basically
invades taiwan what what what is what is
what is the what is the implications of
that will we get dragged into some war
between um america and china
and of course
boris johnson sort of bumbled his way
through it all by not ruling out
anything or ruling anything in
but these are these are interesting
times very interesting times because we
are having to re-craft a lot of our
foreign policy of course now that we've
left the european union
i mean you know
as as anna says that theresa may
her question on the front of the times
tell us that the deal would drag britain
to war
the message from the uk to china has
been that there's no cause for concern
you don't need to be worried but but
should actually it be as anna says that
we actually should be more concerned
about whether we will become dragged
into a relationship with china that we
possibly don't necessarily want to have
on the world stage
yeah i mean look one of the downsides is
that we have a prime minister who
doesn't seem to be capable of strategic
thought so most of the decisions that he
takes are very very deeply
self-interested they're usually very
short-termist their reaction to events
as they're taking place you saw that you
know with the reshuffle you're seeing it
again in this case many other prime
ministers might have come to the same
conclusion especially faced with his
backbenchers and desperately trying to
find something that they can cooperate
with the american president on given you
know joe biden sort of outrage over the
manner in which the irish issue and the
peace process has been treated by boris
johnson so on that basis they're making
judgments i think when theresa may asks
those questions what she's really doing
she's one of those figures that you know
has become much more impressive out of
downing street than she ever was in it
you do have to wonder occasionally why
some people can't try to live up to the
full ability when they're actually in
that building and have to wait until
they're back on the back benches but
there we are i mean what you were sort
of getting at with boris was have you
thought through the potential outcomes
from the current course of action that
you're taking as it happens the course
of action you're taking right now it
seems very sensible but when you've got
a figure like him you are going to have
that concern and i suspect that that's
exactly the concern that theresa may has
anna do you think that we may regret
this deal or do you think that this is
part of of the new post-brexit world
that britain has to forge these kind of
deals to set itself apart from other
countries and other organizations
well i think it's a very big mistake if
we think that we are no longer going to
have an ally in the european union or
other the countries within the european
union and that somehow we have to cast
them adrift um because we we're going to
have forging new relations whether it's
in trade or defense with other countries
and of course
as a member of the european union we sat
so beautifully between what was meant to
be that special relationship with the
united states our membership the
european union and so we were we were
often seen as an arbitrator if you like
between the the states
and between the european union and that
was to our terrific advantage and it
gave us a a grown-up voice on the
international stage which i think has
pretty much disappeared and a lot of
this deal you know johnson will love it
because it makes him feel important
um and you know about no doubt part of
his so-called global britain
but breen i suppose the point is how
important is the uk to this
deal
it's being played across the rest of the
world you know to the front of the new
york times as a as an american australia
deal and that britain is very much a bit
partner in it
yeah i mean you know lots of the
assistance is going to to australia and
obviously geographically that's what
makes it very pertinent i mean
the real question we end up asking is
just how important is britain to america
and if you want an answer to that you
only have to go through the news
headlines we've been seeing you know
three weeks ago a month ago when it
comes to afghanistan i mean there was no
notion that you know britain was a
partner to america america could barely
be bothered to tell us what it was doing
when it was leading afghanistan this was
not trump you know this is not an austin
an hour nationalist president this is
joe biden someone who said he wanted to
repair you know american national
standing and it wasn't just britain by
the way it was the whole of europe you
know what happens in afghanistan washes
up on europe shorts and insecurity and
refugee flows i didn't barely bother to
even talk to anyone in europe about it
and that made britain look you know
humiliated in a way that was simply
objectively accurate to our position if
you're going to base the entirety of
your foreign policy and working with
america you better recognize the fact
that you're going to be a junior partner
in a way that we were not when we for
instance cooperate with france the other
great military power in europe you could
see that lack of capacity there none of
that would have changed here the only
you know both australia and britain are
add-ons to this scenario and australia
for geopolitical reasons obviously has a
more dominant role
uh anna it has taken the uh the
headlines off of the political reshuffle
though uh and while we've got you on um
what are your thoughts about
the movements the deck chairs that have
been moved around the deck over the last
24-48 hours
that's a very good way to describe it
because a lot of this is is just moving
people around i mean you know obviously
a few people were sacked and most of
them should have well to the two that
williamson and january should have gone
at least a year ago not dominant
when they
oh and well rob should have had the
decency to resign
shouldn't have needed to be sacked i
mean he was on holiday of this huge
failure in foreign policy and the man
was on on holiday
and refused to come back and got a free
got a holiday pass from boris johnson if
he'd got any decency at all he would
have resigned so he's had to be booted
out but of course he's been you know
he's only he's not good enough to be
foreign secretary but he is good enough
apparently to be the deputy prime
minister in the event that the prime
minister is in some way incapacitated he
could be our prime minister i mean it's
outrageous uh and as you know i know
it's been reported in other places my
views about the appointment of people
like nadine doris which just sums up how
useless
um boris johnson is and and you do
actually have now a cabinet i think of
sycophants and mates i mean there are
some good people in that cabinet don't
get me wrong but unfortunately they're
all mates of johnson's and so nobody is
going to stand up to it and you won't
have the good debate that you need in a
capital
um you're not going to have any form of
debate and discussion and there are no
big beasts and there are no big people
with big ideas and then as our foreign
secretary we have liz trust who remember
had to be removed when she was lord
chancellor and secretary of state
justice because she was rubbish in that
job
ian do you think that that we're seeing
indeed do you think that that
you know some people are wondering that
a lot of people who've got these roles
must know all the bodies are buried
yeah i mean
there was a bit of that i mean you
always had gavin williamson trying to
not so subtly suggest that he knew where
the bodies were buried from when he was
aware hasn't worked out for him very
well he's now sat on the back ventures i
mean most of the time
you saw people just trying to spare
their blushes really but you look at how
boris johnson spared the blushes of
dominic rob i mean he gave him
basically britain's criminal justice
system you know as a consolation prize
now that's been in a state for 10 years
now you know prisons dilapidated
prisoners being trauma at sky high
levels of suicide self-harm violent
assault traumatizing prisoners rather
than rehabilitating a probation service
that was what privatized
split apart into various sections then
de-privatised put back together all of
this just under this tory you know
administration
courts hundreds of courts in england and
wales closed down whole sways of the law
where you don't have access to any kind
of legal aid just a complete sort of
implosion of our capacity to deliver
justice in this country and why does
that happen why because we've had eight
justice secretaries over ten years
that's how much we care about the
position and how did most of them get it
the same way that rob gets it now
because you just don't you treat it like
a waste paper basket to dump someone in
when they failed somewhere else so you
can spare their blushes i mean that
really you look at that and just think
if this is the way to run a country you
know
it's no wonder that we've ended up in
such a terrible mess
you mentioned dominic rob being on
holiday um anna and and the possible
ditching of the pcr tests for travellers
is on the front of the telegraph uh they
do cost a lot don't they do you think
this is going to be welcomed
do you think it's a good idea to do it
hugely
absolutely i mean i've just come back
from um ten days in portugal so i have
experienced these tests and i've paid
the money um i have to say not reported
in any of the papers to my knowledge
that members of people who live in the
european union actually have that
vaccine passport and they they just have
to show that
and there are a few countries where you
do have to take tests
when you arrive in those countries but
for for us as brits of course have one
of the highest infection rates in the
world it is it is extremely ironic that
we when we come back from countries
which have lower rates than us somehow
we have to take tests but it does need a
huge reform um if you've been double
jabbed
and you can prove that you've got that
double vaccination i don't see why you
certainly don't understand why you have
to take a pcr test
it also feels very expensive i've
cancellated about 150 pounds the flights
by the way were about 60 quid yeah i
mean the whole thing no we had a similar
and we need we need to get our airlines
up you know and we need to get our
tourist industry regenerated and this is
one of the ways to do it we had a
similar experience as a family and i
sort of felt that the pcr tests when you
come back to the uk that you have to do
and you send them off
you know they were all negative but but
you sort of think well who's who's
monitoring that if they if they weren't
would we nobody would we have been
contacted it just seemed like a slightly
pointless exercise i have to say
yeah i i i agree with you but
anyway hopefully common sense is now
going to break out um in the front of
the times uh also focusing on holidays
holy hot spots off covered red list in
time for the half term break so it was
as well as as the the regulations
changing we might see this traffic light
system changing um is this a good idea
or or are we going to see a huge spike
in
in covert numbers if everybody piles
onto planes and goes off to try and get
a bit of winter sun in october
well let's be clear that we're going to
see a spike in i mean
you never know absolutely and we thought
that in the summer and it didn't
transpire but it would be very
surprising if we don't see a rise in
copper cases over this period regardless
of what's going on with travel because
it's going to get colder people are
going to be inside more we know that in
those kind of situations in a pub or
people are drinking when they're talking
loudly these are the kind of places you
get infections
what we're hoping and what seems to be
the case if you're instance look at the
public health england report the rit
very recently came out on waning
immunity on how unlikely it is that
people with vaccines are not being
hospitalized or
at the worst dying that we won't see
quite so high differently i mean when
this when we started implementing the
system for travel we had much more
severe restraints domestically now i
think that they opened up travel too
quickly they certainly opened up
domestically too quickly and far too
extensively but given that we have done
that it is quite it seems like a bit of
a misnomer
the the severity of the international
travel system and to be honest if you
can find someone who really understands
the traffic i mean the traffic lights
are hard enough to understand before
they added that sort of
what was france in a sort of a yellow
plus category so by the time that it
moved on to it wasn't even a traffic
light anymore it was essentially a
mathematical
yeah so i mean by this point you just
think well okay clear the whole thing
out which seems to be the way that
they're going
welcome back you're watching the press
preview uh we've been out ian dunde and
anna subery um and the front of the
telegraph uh is your choice for this
section and ian this is about pretty
patel um telling the police to get tough
on climate protesters after it emerged
that there's footage which the telegraph
has seen which shows the police
escorting some of these protesters onto
the motorway because it was a they made
apparently a dynamic risk assessment
yeah i don't know i will worry before we
did this that we were going to agree on
too many things so i suspect this is
going to be an area in which we disagree
um
yeah i mean we we've seen this before we
saw actually you remember when they
toppled the statue in bristol when
people asked why didn't the police
intervene then the thing is the police
on the scene have to make an assessment
as to risks i mean you've got a bunch of
people who are trying to get onto a
motorway there is a very obvious
potential for risk it doesn't really to
celebrate what the protesters are doing
i get very irritated with this kind of
environmental protest and i think as if
you're if you're committed to doing
something about climate change pretty
much the worst pr you can do
is this attempt to just sort of almost
aggressively you know get in the way of
people's lives and just stop them from
being able to do really quite elementary
things but that risk assessment we leave
up to the police for a reason which is
that they are there to protect lunch to
facilitate protest but to protect lives
and they have to do it on the scene okay
instead what we've got now you could
tell is this very aggressive attempt to
sort of you know say the police or you
know sort of the suggestion is that
they're woke and that they you know that
they're helping the politicians too much
there's someone in that copy quoted
they're saying we need to treat them
like islamic terrorists and interesting
that doesn't mean justice to
thousands
we're running out of time so i just
quickly want to get anna's thoughts on
this we've only got 30 seconds on it um
but i am very much of the view that the
police should actually that they their
their role is to protect citizens and to
maintain law and order people have a
right peaceful protest but also they
have a right to go about their business
and you have to get the balance right
and i think that the met police in
particular and this is my own experience
from demonstrations outside parliament
when i was a member of parliament and i
think they've got it wrong i think
they've gone from one extreme when you
might remember there was a man who died
when they were kettling people which was
absolutely the wrong way to police
protests now to the situation where
pretty much any protester can do
anything and everybody else is just
tough and and on that i think that i
don't care what the issue is by the way
i don't discriminate on it the police
should police it properly just like they
would anything else okay they've gone
too far the other way we're out of time
for this hour uh but anna and thank you
both very much you're going to stay with
us and give us your thoughts as we go
through the rest of the day's news after
the break